we started doing some sort of autometer
Theory earlier this year and then we
have a bit of a break because I think
you went ganting in Far Away places and
I was busy with other things as well and
now we going to pick up the threat again
and continue talking about uh autom
Theory and formal languages and stuff um
I mean if it is regular Expressions I
hear these are kind of like some people
have bad dreams about these is that
right like like this one
here one puzzle is to find out in one
word in one sentence what does this
regular expression mean yeah because it
has got a very short description I mean
in English uh and and and one uh
exercise is to find out what it
is so regular expression are they to
Define what we call regular languages
and maybe can I write something in the
previous videos we looked at DFAS which
are deterministic finite autometer and
we looked at nfas which are
non-deterministic finite autometer and
they were little machines I mean DFAS
are little machine they have a state and
then they read a symbol and they go to
another state and they recognize you
give them a string and it says yes or no
yeah and the nfas are slight variation
where there is s some some non
determinism could be go here or could go
there but there are all little machines
so first of all every DFA is an NFA and
we can also uh as more interesting turn
an NFA into DFA by a power automat
construction and so hence we can see
that they Define the same set of
languages and intuitively there are the
languages which uh which we can uh
recognize with a computer program which
uses only fixed finite amount of memory
but today we look at a different angle
on the same languages and these are
called regular
expressions and in a way that's quite
interesting because regular expression
give a more sort of denotational view on
regular languages instead of looking at
it as bya via machines we we we look at
a high level description of these
languages and regular expressions are
actually very useful so they they are
used in in uh in editor commands to to
to describe editing patterns or you can
also write
um something called a stream editor
where you can give a pattern and and you
can do automatic s of editing job so if
you want to do some simple text
processing you use this SED and then
there's another program under un called
grap which recognizes all all regular I
mean tries to match regular Expressions
to some input and and and gives you
prints all the all the lines where it
appears no matter what the amount of
input is grap can filter out or show you
the things that you're interested in and
that can be very useful it's very useful
uh to learn regular Expressions they
also have applications in like compiler
writing uh so when you to Define what is
a number or what is what is a symbol I
mean what is a variable name and so on
then you usually start with defining
them by regular expressions and then
there's another level uh which is called
context free grammar but it's usually in
two levels so first of all the tokens
are recognized via regular expressions
and the tokens are then processed uh to
give uh
via VIA a grammar which we haven't yet
looked at let me continue this picture a
little bit I will tell you what regular
expressions are in more detail and then
I I I I I I give give a semantics in
terms of sets where every regular
expression gives rise to a set of vers
but this doesn't really help us to to
write a program which recognizes uh a
string or not because the set is
infinite so so how do we do this so
instead we will Define a translation
into nfas there's all the translation
the other way around which I'm not going
to look at today which is quite fun and
shows that regular expressions and
autometer Define the same set of
languages that's interesting from a
theoretical point of view okay let's
look at some regular Expressions so I'm
going Define regular Expressions the set
of regular Expressions oh oh before I do
this we had to fix an alphabet Sigma
just a finite set so for example Sigma
could be all
uh
letters I'm not writing 26 letters now
okay like this and then we Define given
an alphabet we Define a regular the set
of regular expressions and for every
regular expression so if you have an
like an e which is a regular expression
then I Define the language of e which is
a a set of words so it's it's a subset
of sequences of strings over this
alphabet so this is just to be reading
strings over Sigma and the language is a
set of strings not all of them some of
them okay okay we have we have already
seen this when we did automa but that's
so long ago that we maybe want to watch
these videos again I don't know okay so
what are regular Expressions so I showed
one example but let me give you some
more examples so for example just the
word like
hello is a regular expression and what
is the language of this regular
expression no it's very booring it's
just a set containing only the word
hello okay just the word or just those
letters I mean is it no there a word
it's not there's no comma in between
just said there just one element and
there one element is one uh word or like
say string yeah which is the the word
hello this isn't the alphabet that makes
up that word this is that word no the
alphabet is in the moment the letters
from A to Z yeah yes okay and we have
one one uh word which is hello and this
is the language of the regular
expression hello okay now it's a bit
boring now in German I say hello is an A
so now I can write this I can say is are
you from Germany yes I'm from Germany
surprise for many but I am okay born in
Berlin okay so we can write plus this
plus this now okay I don't want okay let
me just call this expression Ian yeah
and then the language of Ean is no
points for this hello and hello but
that's a bit here I'm I'm repeating lots
of things so let me write another
regular expression E2 I write the
regular expression H and then see either
e or a l l o and this is the same
language so so so L of E2 is also these
two words because you can read an a h
and then an e or an A and then l o so is
that e plus a but that just means you
could have e there is it you mean yeah
the plus is a part of forming regular
expression you have either e or a you
have first an h and then an E and A and
then in l o and that means you have the
words hello and hello but now let's
let's get a bit more interesting let's
get a bit more interesting which
language is this let's do something more
interesting okay okay let's do the star
Let's see we want to add hello but any
number of else so now we have a language
which is not finite anymore more because
I can have no
l here H then hello
hello oh no that's just hello and then
now it's
hello and so on yeah so if you do a star
you can repeat this any number of times
yeah whatever is under the star okay let
me let me go on this is yeah let me show
you some more regular expressions and
I'm changing the alphabet I'm changing
the the alphabet to only a b c okay A B
C and now I want to have the regular
expression of all the words which
contain AB so how do I do this I say
okay in the beginning I have a sequence
of A's and B's and C's then I have an
A and then I have another sequence of
A's and B's and C's I mean I don't want
write down this in language of
infinitely many words but they're
exactly the words over ABC which
somewhere contain an AB I can also
contain several ABS that doesn't matter
okay yeah and you read this so like this
so you can repeat a b c which is like
anything and then after a while you can
say a and then you repeat a b c again so
this could be ABA or yeah okay yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah okay let's do some
so for example in this okay let's E4 so
some examples is
yeah uh is in this language in the
language of
E4 so what's not in this in this
language uh for example b a a is not in
the language right and so on okay yeah
shall we do another one I want the one
which contains
the an an even number of A's oh do I
know how to do this okay maybe it's too
complicated you can do it you got this
you got this yeah yeah so I have an A
and then after the a there is some B's
and C's and then there's another a and I
may do this in number any number of
times but then I may have in the
beginning some B's and C's and then
after have some B's and C's what's the
idea so we see some B's and C's then we
see some A's then there some B's and C's
maybe also none then there's another a
and we repeat this so we obious get an
even number of A's including no A's
right and and then there's some more B's
and C's this is where zero is an even
number again right yeah yeah zero is an
even number yeah okay um so
um this is quite an interesting puzzle
um because uh we can also there's a
theorem which I which actually I can
just proof I can sketch that for every
regular expression there's also one
which is exactly the negation of this
one yeah and this is another challenge
to find the regular expression which
defines uh all the words which do not
contain AB I mean had this AB this one
is is easy because then you have an odd
number of A's so that that's not so
difficult but the the language of all
words or the regular expression defining
all the words which do not contain AB
yeah that's a bit tricky it's good for
for puzzles I maybe there should be a
little puzzle game you know we'll leave
that for exercise for the viewers maybe
yeah okay so let me do one more uh I
want to have the sequence of a of a but
only always interchanging a b a b yeah
or B a one way or the other alternating
alternating yeah alternating is a good
word yeah so so what I do I say
AB in bracket star yeah so a b a b but
now it may start with a B so I say
either b or nothing and nothing is
written Epsilon yeah Epsilon is nothing
nothing empty word the empty string and
and then after I have also a plus
Epsilon so that maybe an A in the end it
has doesn't have to end with a B so
that's a regular expression defining
like a b a b or b a b a and and so on
okay okay so now we have seen some
examples now let's do the math regular
Expressions so I'm defining the set of
regular expressions and assume there is
given a sigma so Sigma is my is my is a
finite set of symbols the first regular
expressions are a bit strange maybe you
may want to have the empty language so
no words so I write empty is a regular
expression okay and the language of
empty is surprise surprise the empty set
MH okay so okay these two symbols look
the same but one of them is a regular
expression and the other one is the same
just to confuse everybody okay so now we
have another regular expression which we
have already seen I mean the zero is is
is almost never used namely the regular
expression which stands for the set
containing only the empty word is the
set and Epsilon here is now a ver so
Epsilon is the empty string the problem
is it's very difficult to write the
empty string right this Epsilon is this
string is intentionally left blank
yeah that's how to read it okay so what
comes next we had symbols so if you have
a symbol from Sigma so a is here a
variable maybe yeah it's not the letter
a is any any any symbol then a is also
regular expression and the language of a
is just the set containing only the word
containing
only so so any any any symbol also is a
ver of lengths one this is is a string
of length
one okay so we so what else do we have
then we can put one regular expression
after the other so that's that's this if
if you have le little letters for e is a
regular
expression and F is a regular
expression then I can form
EF is a regular expression and the idea
is so a ver over e f say the first part
is something from E and the second part
is something from F so so how I Define
this so if I have a word v which is in
the language of
e and the word w which is in the
language of
f then I can concatenate these words
like strings I can concatenate them and
they are in the language of e f so I
think we have seen this in the examples
that so here for example if you look at
the language of this thing here it's b
or the empty word right and here we have
all these
ab ab ab and so on and the language here
is a and Epsilon and now if you form all
the combinations of word from these
three sets you get exactly the language
we wanted what's missing uh Plus I
haven't done plus plus is actually
easier so so again I have e is a regular
expression and F is a regular
expression and now I can form e+ f as a
regular expression we've also seen
example for the plus right and that's
very simple in this case L of e plus
f is either avert from e or Union avert
from f
so that's just set theoretic Union there
one thing missing what is missing you
have to define the
star okay so if a is a regular
expression then e star is a regular
expression and it means I can repeat e
any number of times including none so
how do I Define the language so I say
okay first of all the empty word so this
is an absent is an element looks very
similar is in L of
E and then we say okay if we have a word
v which is in the language of e and we
have already formed a word in
elistar and we can put them
together and form a word an
listar that's a you see here is
inductive definition we can repeat this
rule any number of times so we can do
this so that's the the the formal
definition of the language of a regular
expression Define two things we the set
of regular Expressions given an alphabet
and then we Define the language so now
we know what regular expressions are and
uh we have Define the language uh using
a bit of math bit of set theory uh I'm
not a fan of set theory by the way so we
know I have defined the the semantics
but we still don't know how to run a
regular expression how to recognize
whether a ver is in the language because
language is infinite so we're going to
do this so we we going to define the
translation from regular expression into
nfas and I'm going to do this in Python
so what we're going to do we Define the
the the the type of regular or the class
of regular expression in Python and then
I will Define the translation into the
nfas which we have also defined in
Python and if we put and we know how to
run an NFA yeah as we defined how to run
an NFA so now I'm translating the
regular into an NFA and I can run it and
this way I can actually have a
recognizer for my regular expressions
and actually uh this is more efficient
even if you just want to grab a match a
word no stars just a word then if you do
this by hand it it's can be a bit
inefficient because you have to to go
back you have to to to look at some
letters several times sometimes like if
it's if it's overlapping but if you use
this regular expression translation it's
linear it will look at every symbol only
once so it's actually a useful
programming idea how to translate
regular Expressions into into autometer
and that's the next video then right
yeah now let's do the math okay if we
must hooray you should say you might ask
me some
questions yeah so I'm going to
concentrate I'm going to be there yes
concentrate poter concentrate